[Music]
I have so many questions uh for for the
whole team here but miam I mean just to
kick it off can you talk about when you
when this what was the original idea
that came to you was it always did you
always conceive of it as this sprawling
Saga or was there like were you starting
with one small part of this family story
that then grew and and when did you
start it it was revenge against my
brothers no I'm just kidding it worked
we had to share one bathroom it was hard
um honestly it started be careful when
you tell stories it started when I was
at a creative Capital Retreat and I was
telling stories about smuggling tapes
into Iran and about family secrets and
there was some people laughing so hard
and one of those people was Natalie
Difford from sin reach and uh if you
know C they did like beast of the
Southern Wild they actually financed the
post of my film lot of great films and
she was like you have to make that into
a a film and I was like yeah whatever
who wants wants who wants to hear that
but then when Trump took power and like
everything started becoming very diff
uncomfortable for immigrants in this
country I thought you know maybe it is a
good time to write such a story to tell
our own stories because I felt like as
Iranian Americans were as a young child
we were villainized as you know as you
see in the film for being terrorists
with the hostage crisis later on the AES
of evil than the Muslim band so I
thought it would be a great place to
start but I didn't know where to start
so the first script was like 190 Pages
it was about all my family members and
then slowly I started to realize it
really is a story of me and my mother
and of three generations of women so I
was able to you know develop it they
were the world's best development um
producers because they were always were
letting me find my voice in the process
in the probably 12 drafts that I wrote
um but they let me come they were they
were giving me feedback but they were
always looking to make cuz it's not a
traditional structure they didn't try to
fit it into a traditional 3A structure
you know they just let me find my voice
in the process so it was great I I
wanted to ask you about well two two
related things one is the structure and
the second is tone and I think they're
related but how early in the process did
you know it was going to take sort of a
nonlinear structure and and be told in
this way did you write it in a more
linear way and then cut it up and move
things I never wrote it linearly um I
have to say it was always nonlinear um I
knew I wanted to make a comedy but a
Persian comedy so you have to laugh and
cry that's part of our culture um so I
knew it had those elements I I the
section that's the mother section was
essentially always exactly as it was um
and I knew you know we played with the
idea of it being earlier but I wanted
you to kind of not like the mother in
the beginning you know to kind of
through Leila's story kind of feel like
she had a difficult relationship with
this woman but then and it's it's a
question of empathy it's like it was a I
was challenging the audience to be
empathetic because it's someone you
don't like and through the process of
the film you realize you don't really
know her just as a daughter doesn't know
her and we peel back the layers and then
by the end you're crying for her which
was my secret weapon you you have just
just described my experience of watching
the film because it I mean it really is
and so that goes the tonal question
where like in the beginning it's very
fun and effervescent and the 80s you
know the color and music and everything
thing and yeah the mom is a kind of
unappealing figure to me and by the end
yeah I was crying like that relationship
becomes so beautiful but the the tonal
shift like when it becomes about the mom
as a as the 13-year-old girl and we cast
a real 13-year-old so we really wanted
to the audience to feel what it was like
for her I think you know I always knew
that each section would have a different
tone and that was a challenging thing to
like communicate to the different heads
of departments because you know and it's
a very test you know testimony to the
editors um is that I knew the first one
was like I'm a person that was
influenced by 80s romcoms and like TV
shows I grew up in a immigrant household
in America but TV shows and films were
the way I learned to be American so
she's very influenced by that the
character so it has that feeling pop
feeling the grandmother is a spaghetti
western because grandmothers tell tall
tales and then the mother is more like a
cir steming neuro realist feel and I
think you know Joanne can talk about
this it's you know we wanted to keep the
playfulness throughout you know the tone
of this narrator who's trying to find
out her Origins throughout but then you
know there is a shift because someone
else takes the reign of the narration
which was always the second I cracked
the script where it went from 180 Pages
wo those poor producers to 90 pages that
section always stayed the same the
breaking because I knew the mother was a
co- narrator in some ways um and then
Joanne's job was to make you know and
she came she's was the first editor was
Iranian British and then Joanne came in
for the second half and it was really to
kind of hone the fun playfulness and to
create a sense of unity in a film that
has different tones and that's a
testimony to I mean Joanne was a you
know she was she's a master Craftsman so
craftswoman sorry crafts
person is it
I think it is
yeah um no it was it was you know oh
sorry classic okay here we go um okay
got no uh no I mean it was that was also
what made it really exciting and
challenging I think you know also not a
typical structure not a standard
traditional way of
Storytelling um it it offers challenges
for sure um but that was like the really
fun part about it and exploring it
together and seeing what worked and
seeing ways to weave sort of the story
we had just witnessed and told and bring
that back in in a way that um you know
we we feel connected um and we remember
so those words that um you know Shireen
says at the end about being connected to
her daughter like being silent um and
remembering those moments that we've
just witnessed in lighter times you know
um so and a lot of uh we did a lot of I
mean this is great for filmmakers is
that we did a lot of the rewrite in post
because it always had voiceover but we
wanted to get the tone exactly right so
we kind of throw out a lot of the
original narr and we made it more
playful and we changed it according to
the cut and to what we were seeing so
poor Lea who plays the lead she was on a
TV show and I was constantly sending her
hey can you record these 10 10 lines hey
could you do it this way and I was
giving her constant Direction and she
was sending it to us on our iPhone as a
temp and we were every day getting 10 to
20 lines that we were trying to get the
tone right for the Final Cut and you
know she was an amazing partner Joanne
and I like it was a process of
improvisation in some ways in post you
know I wasn't you know 100% like saying
it has to be as I you know shot it we
were knew that voiceover could be a
great tool in in a greater way than it
was in the original script so we
continued Joan and I would be joking we
have like hundreds of tracks and many of
them didn't get it into the film that we
would try and it didn't work and then we
would try something else and so we were
constantly
experimenting um I mean the voiceover
obviously leaves a lot of options
Endless Options Endless Options um so
but yeah it was really great you know um
to have that opportunity to you know
they say the editing process is the
final rewrite and we really did that um
together it was such a dynamic
experience with both editors to really
the first editor was really to keep
things because for a lot you know you're
like ah just cut it it sucks it's
horrible and he'd be like patience you
know it's trust your work and so the
first editor was really about
maintaining what I had written as much
as possible without me you know
discarding it just because it didn't
work yet um so I think it's like a great
collaboration I I think it's similar to
like my collaboration with rosem rustem
and I you know we talked a lot about how
do we synthesize things that are very
desparate it's like you have the Iranian
experience you have the Iranian American
experience and there are things
sometimes that are unexpected that we
wanted to do like in the whole sequence
where the mother is leaving Iran you
might have typically put a queue in
there that was Iranian but we chose a
queue that rosam had you know a song
rosam himself had worked on that was an
American queue and it was a way to
connect Iran and America together so you
were never far away there was the
Storyteller was in America but it was
about Iran so we were
subconsciously connecting you to the
time periods even though you're watching
the Iran section for 26 minutes there
are American cues put in there so that
you don't feel it so far away and then
rosan was constantly that was well that
was from the very first cut I saw of
this movie that song was in there and it
really took me by surprise you're like
what but I was yeah I was partly shocked
cuz I thought it really worked so well
um the first few cues that I wrote for
this film like wrote to picture I sent
them to Mariam and she was like M she
was like cuz I I guess I I I looked at
this project I was like this is an
opportunity to really like go deep into
the Persian music that I grew up
listening to and like to to do a pretty
ethnic score that's what I that's what I
sort of envisaged before I got my hands
dirty and the first thing I I sent um
Mariam it was actually the scene where
all the brothers show up at the hospital
and it was just like there was tons of
Persian instruments it was modal it was
like kind of Grand in a way and she was
like she was like you you made it you
made this scene look so tribal and like
this is not it and at first I was like
oh oh this sucks because I really wanted
to go hardcore Persian music and but she
was really right when she explained to
me like you know the family's been
living in Brooklyn for 20 years at this
point they this can't be where the the
Persian music isn't and and after that I
like sort of started to understand how
it made sense for a movie that is about
an immigrant family to really like
Express that musically yeah we became I
mean I don't know I'm not musically
trained so I don't know how to talk in
music talk I always talk in narrative
ways but yeah I mean I think it was a
really deep conversation that we don't
feel alienated from these people just
because they're from a different culture
in America I wanted them to feel
familiar and then when we do use Persian
instrumentation it's very particular and
it's it's used in a for a particular
narrative device but I thought too early
in the film is an alienating experience
so and then obviously at the end we have
a Persian version of Girls Just Want to
Have Fun which Ros did with our uh
actress new plays the mother and there
that's a perfect synthesis of me you
know smuggling music to Iran and then it
being affected by Iran and coming back
to us at the end of the film so I
thought that was a fun you know Russ was
that a was that a a remix or is that a
complete redo of the song yes it's
completely from scratch and the funny
thing is it's amazing yeah Joanne was in
the room when when miam told me that
like you know one more thing oh it's
like 5 days before we're locking it's
like the 20th of or like the 16th of
December and you know you're about to go
to Tokyo and I'm like just one small
thing so can you make me a new version
Girls Just Want to Have Fun yeah so it
was kind of a Mad Dash but that's
something that you get accustomed to to
doing
and and yeah it was it was a really I
think it's honestly probably my favorite
thing that I that I made for the movie
even though it's not technically an
original composition
but I think it's amazing I makes the I
mean the everything makes that final
scene but that song is like yeah yeah it
feels it feels like I don't know we
we're trying to get it released as its
own thing as a YouTube video so people
can experience music video yeah but who
knows is that going to happen let's
what's the update cross your fingers
where the soundtrack comes out next week
we're trying to also release a music
video around it so but I think it's such
a great you know I think there was a
constant conversation that we had and
that was the it's really interesting
that we did that last it was an
important thing because we had found a
way to communicate with each other and
and we were obviously everyone's always
rushed but we found out we got into
Sundance and we're like oh my God we
have like 14 days to finish the score
and you know it was just a we finished
two days before our Premiere at Sundance
so we were mixing in the new year wow
that's how it always is we were so tired
but it was like you know I think we had
that we had worked together and
obviously I've been a huge fan of rast
stems he says no to everybody so I was
honored he said yes in the first place
and he held you know test screenings at
his house which is so generous but I
think we had you know really found a way
to work with each other so that we got
when we got to that last moment it kind
of was like a culmination of all the
conversations that we had had throughout
the whole process Def and it just made
it that much easier so I have to ask the
cast is absolutely incredible and it's
huge it's sprawling family relations a
lot of people I'm not familiar with
Lindsay I mean can you and miam talk
about how you put this cast together oh
my God it was a a few years I want to
know he like who who who was and this is
just a testament let me just tell you
casting directors are your therapists
because this film was funded right at
the beginning of coid and so we almost
made this film probably four times
before we shot it so every time we would
have an actor and then something would
happen and then we would lose them and
then we'd have to start all over again
and I'd say I'm never going to find
another you mean there were these like
little kids who could have been stars
but Co knocked them out well like for
instance the mother who's played by a
13-year-old was originally her sister
was going to play that role at the time
she was 15 it took another two and a
half years to make the film she can you
talk about her she's extraordinary like
where did you find her where did she
does she live in the US is she in IR she
lives in Iran I wanted an actor from
Iran she's not an actor she's a kid um
originally we had auditioned people in
Iran remotely and I came across the
sister because I knew their family their
family were family friends of ours I
knew her father when the when the mother
was pregnant with her so they knew my
family they were very invested in the
film I had auditioned a lot of people
but they ended up being the right ones
and then she aged out she was too old
and then she said my sister wants
audition I thought your sister what do
you mean she's like this little
pipsqueak but she had hit puberty right
before we shot so she she hit puberty
late but she's much taller than me but
she literally hit puberty in the months
we were prepping the film wow so then
she ended up her sister helped her
prepare for the role because she had
been preparing for two years and didn't
ended up not doing it so she was so
prepared she has a four-page monologue
in one shot when she freezes time it's a
very technically challenging scene on
every level and she I've worked with you
know Academy Award winners that can't
hit their marks like that she would
literally hit the mark every time she's
such a natural and then Lindsay was like
you know Lindsay had to find Lea who
played Lea and and the mother and you
know she's her process is to go through
hundreds of auditions then make me the
short list so were many of the actors
based here in the US or Europe or were
they predominately in Iran we were
considering here take this we have very
spotty microphones sorry we were
considering actors from everywhere we
wanted every actor who could possibly be
right for that role to have the
opportunity but they had to be of
Iranian origin yeah yes uh we wanted to
cast authentically and so we went and
looked all over the world um there it
was such a specific character specific
role um the whole time I was studying
maram and trying to match her energy and
uh Leila ended up being somebody who did
audition in Los Angeles where there's a
large concentration of Iranian American
actors um and she was really the first
one that we built the cast around from
there we cast the mother for other
anyone actors in the audience it's funny
because she was not my original first
choice we had another actress she
couldn't get out of her TV show so we
had to go back to the drawing board she
gave me her top 10 I never even looked
at this actress because Lea no because
the lighting and her makeup was so
horrible I didn't even watch the tape I
was like what is this and then when Co
hit I had tons of time so I was looking
at the top 10 actors in her list and I
found that on Instagram and I said I
called her I'm like is this the same
person and she just had really and I I
said how is your audition so horrible
she said I it was my first audition ever
on tape and my friend did my makeup and
I looked like a clown I was like you
really did um I have to say for for
Leila every time because she auditioned
a lot of times and including chemistry
reads and over and over again just to to
the character developed a lot in the
audition process and every time she
auditioned it was closer and closer
devel until you start just started
getting chills seeing the similarities
that more than anything we liked her
because we wanted a comedian and she is
really amazing with timing like she's a
great comedian and that was so important
to me and you know through the AUD
because you know she has when she got
cast and she has to read with all of
these different people for chemistry
reads she's the lead and you're just
seeing her getting into her own like
through every read through like you saw
her developing as an actor as as a
character so it's like it's interesting
that through the process you get to know
so much about your work and actors get
to know so much about their role if you
because we had all the time in the world
right during Co um so did you cast her
first and then cast Shireen the older
Shireen as her mom or was she much we
were circling two or three people for
each right so around the same time
simultaneous but those two sort of came
together because they have to come as a
package right right cuz we looked at
another actress but there's no way that
she could be nisha's daughter like we
needed to make it look like mother and
daughter
and then when we were casting the
husband we you know the the father role
we looked because that we looked at you
know so many actors around the world and
then when the one who got the role he's
a very well-known actor in London he
read the role he read the scene with new
show we were all balling when he asked
for forgiveness via Zoom we were like
it's him you just know it he's amazing
it's him you know what I mean it's him
and can you talk about the grandmother
cuz she doesn't really have credits as
far as I can tell she's incredible so
Lindsay gets but I was like Lindsay we
had another grandmother but she was very
um judgmental about the role when we
were about to shoot she's like oh your
grandmother's so like I don't know
or something I said what that's a
real person I was so upset I was like
and I said oh my God I tell said to
Lindsay more than anything I was like
she's really judging this character I
don't think she can play the role you
know and Lindsay said you have to let
her go and I said what are you talking
about we took months to find someone it
was really hard to find an older actress
that hasn't had surgery that speaks
Persian and Lindsay said we will find
her right and then I said we made a list
I said I remember a film I saw at reram
by bobc Jal and there was this
interesting woman but we couldn't find
any information about her so Lindsay and
I started becoming detectives and it
turns out she's a very well-known
avanguard artist in San Francisco and
she had been in this one film at R Dam
we couldn't find her contacting her cuz
she has different names so Lindsay found
someone who knew someone who who knew
her and then the moment I talked to her
she was so funny and she loved the role
so much because she said you know older
women never get to have a body they
never get to have sexuality they're
supposed to die when they hit like 60
and not have any desire I love this
script because I get to be you know she
I love having sex with my husband I love
like all the stuff and she helped me
with some of the you know some of the
lines that we did in the film was from
our conversations and she would be
joking and then we added it like she was
never in the dinner scene a lunch scene
originally but she said a funny line of
I told her the back door not the front
door and I said oh my God you have to be
in that scene and I wrote her in because
because of she came up with that line
yeah we we were I was going to ask if
you ever had that conversation with your
grandmother my grandmother had a lot of
conversations like this she was like she
was a lovely woman who um knew No
Boundaries um because when you're the
matriarch you have no one to answer to
and women when they're around each other
they speak very freely you know much to
other people's you know opinions but I
think like I love that we would always
joke and we would and that's how a lot
of the lines came about we would improv
we would joke around oh that's a good
idea and even in the whole process a lot
of the fun stuff that came about was
through improvisation with the actors on
our days off and so it's like very being
awake in the whole process but Bella was
incredible and it's like Lindsay found
her I don't know how you found her but
you eventually found her and ha show was
improv as I
understand show was we were joking
around I was saying I had a boyfriend in
college and I used to always tell him
the wrong words you know and and then
they I had said that to Lila and then
Lila did the same thing to the actor
when we were
rehearsing and cuz she had heard the
story from me and I was like oh that's
perfect so we ended up putting the kafa
show in there um I also Mary I also want
to ask you the visual look of the film
is really stunning and Incredibly Rich
I'm curious just to hear you talk a
little bit about the working with your
production designer and of course also
your cinematographer yeah it's a great
team like and it looks nothing like
circumstance or your other it doesn't
it's very different um so I worked with
um how did I so I had all you know like
the film develops I had different DPS at
different times and then our DP fell out
and we knew we were going to shoot a lot
of it overseas I saw a friend o Aldi she
went through the dock lab with you guys
but she had just done her first feature
she shot an entire film in Turkey on a
boat for $100,000 it's gorgeous it just
premiered and I was like who's that
cinematographer and she oh this crazy
German guy he he shoots a lot of like
documentaries and crazy project very
difficult project she said and he
operates himself and his own steady cam
we're a lowbudget film I'm like as a
producer M he has his own steady Cam
that could be helpful um so I started
talking to him I just love how fluid he
was and he loves to shoot overseas and I
love his visuals he was able to do so
much with so little and we just clicked
and then the production designers I met
they had done a Netflix show in Turkey
they had built this ginormous submarine
actually it's like Tolga kenic he won
Sundance with um
Butterflies from turkey and I had met
him he was that was his production
designer on the Netflix show I was
amazed they made this huge submarine to
scale out of papermache I thought it was
really like when I went to touch it it
wasn't real I was impressed by how
authentic every detail in the submarine
was and I said to the the local grp we
have this is the people we have to use
so we were able to like blend these two
great talents and the dop was just like
a lot of books and especially costume I
made I make a lot of very detailed books
for every Department like a 100 plus
pages and then they in return make their
own books so in response to my book so
that was really nice um the much the
dismay with the costume designer she
realized I hate the color orange you'll
never see like orange is not a real
color in my film she had got all this
orange stuff I'm like oh no so like she
learned through the process she had to
eliminate that color um but it was great
I mean we there was a really always a
dialogue like so I gave a book of all my
hundreds of photos of my family in New
York and the production designers
created that Brooklyn apartment or they
created my mom's office from photos that
I had sent them M and and they would
give me very detailed breakdown of what
what their response to my photos were
wow so it was cool um jumping ahead I
want to ask um so the film is it's about
to come out in the US and then one week
in one week um I'm curious um I assume
circumstance has found its way into Iran
and is available there right it's a very
popular it was a popular black market
DVD yeah yeah do they sell DVDs I don't
know yeah they must um I'm just curious
your thoughts about this I'm sure
eventually will find its way into Iran
don't tell Sony yeah um yeah I mean my
first I mean it's funny I mean have you
I guess I'm just like what are your
thoughts about that or do you think
about that as part of your audience like
you want that as part of your audience
you uh oh it's interesting because our
like the guy who did all the animation
he's lives in Iran so we I never met him
he works completely remotely so I was
very curious to what someone in Iran
would think obviously the actress is
from Iran so we showed some people some
clips and they it was very I show them
the first 15 minutes cuz of that crazy
montage and they really I was I would he
brought his friends the animator so 10
people came to watch it as we were
watching it on zoom and I was zooming
into their faces and they were all
laughing I was like yes you know like I
wondered if it would translate to
someone overseas and the way I met the
first editor was like he lives in London
but he had seen my film when he was a
film student in Tron and he loved the
film and so when he found out I was
making the film he he had reached out to
me personally about saying he wanted you
know how he had been a fan and stuff so
that's how we ended up meeting um and he
ended up working on this so hopefully
you know hopefully after its theatrical
run which starts next week in LA in New
York and then expands on November 3rd
hopefully after that's all over I hope
it yeah of course I mean Persians are
amaz Iranians are amazing at pirating
and no offense dubbing
like when Game of Thrones would be out
they'd be like subtitling it the next
day it'd be up on YouTube um they love
they love Cinema they love series
they're they're really like this is such
an important part of how they get around
restrictions of how they express
themselves they're so connected to the
world even though they're in Iran I'm
always amazed at how that is but clearly
when you started this project started
the writing was it like
a it was a different moment in Iran and
now today as it's coming out you know
after a year of woman light freedom and
everything it's crazy like who would
know like you know when I was premiering
this it was this such an amazing
energetic time around the woman life
Freedom Movement but I think you know my
films often are always only exclusively
deal with strong women who fight against
the status quo and this movement was not
born yesterday this is a movement that's
ongoing and we're so happy that you know
we have the Nobel Prize winner nagas
muhamedi Iranian feminists won the prize
this year
um you know it's such a huge moment for
us but that isn't born from something
that happens in a day right you know
that's an ongoing struggle that's a
struggle of women even before the
Revolution you know it's my mother's era
I mean fighting against the patriarchy
unfortunately is not something that's
born you know today not here not
anywhere so I think it's like a
Continuum of women fighting for their
rights well said um well it is it's so I
just to to go back to the beginning of
our conversation it it to me it's so
powerful you really achieved that the
relationship between the mother and
daughter with everything else going on
in the film like that core relationship
is so that's a challenge also like to
have something epic but to have
something intimate and that's something
we had a constant conversation with
about the dop you know Joan and I had
this conversation like how do you create
a sense of epicness but you but you have
to care about the people too at the same
time so it's it's a challenge it's it's
amazing I mean I found myself getting
moved in the in the second half and
especially towards the end where I'm
getting choked up I'm like God damn it
how did she do that because it's this it
is this big family die hard like New
Yorkers that last week were like crying
I said what's going on and stuff yeah I
believe it so I think it's Sneaky and I
think I was talking with a uh um a
writer about this is I think you get
more emotional because it's funny yeah
like I think if it was all like very
intense you wouldn't feel the same or if
it was all very funny you wouldn't feel
the same I think the ju a position of
funny and emotional next to each other
is surprising and so you kind of you hit
those emotions a little harder than you
normally would I
think so one last question just going
back to the young Shireen is do you know
is she planning to pursue acting now did
this did she enjoy this process is I
tortured her no um she actually came to
Sundance it was her first time in
America and her first time in America
was in at the Sundance Film Festival
surreal for her um and you know she
could have stayed in America but she
decided she wanted to go back and it was
important for her to go back and make
change in her own country um so I give
her a lot of we were so scared when she
was going back that something would
happen to her you know thankfully it
didn't um but she's a top student in her
High School number one student but she's
really gotten the acting bug and the
mother the woman who plays a grandmother
is in touch with a lot of acting coaches
in Iran so now she's taking private
classes um and is starting to do some
Workshop stuff um so she she's really
enjoyed the process she's a great talent
amazing yeah well thank you all so much
for being here congratulations again
thank you everyone Mariam
[Applause]
[Music]
kesar